what a few days stretch for this guy he
called
but he and charles davis are a
phenomenal listen on cbs
uh calls the bills beating the ravens
then
his son noah calls the
saints beating the bears on nickelodeon
which was a phenomenal broadcast in that
respect
and then he's also the voice of the
brooklyn nets
in brooklyn new york hardin joins that
group
just yesterday and he's blessed enough i
mean the man's called the hail murray
he's also called the miracle of miami
essentially if the catskills and gus
johnson had a baby it would be on eagle
wow of cbs joining me right here how's
that for an introduction on what about
that
well i i'd like to see that conception
very intriguing my
my phone is ringing off the hook as you
can well imagine
yes i've had to hire a personal
assistant in the last six hours
fat bad tell them no tell them no
i'll call them back tomorrow tomorrow
yeah
bad tomorrow we're good by the way
first of all outstanding use of fad by
the way
i feel like that's the quintessential
assistant
that is that the assistant
is great that wow uh
let's start with the uh the addition of
james harden to this team
uh and how in the world how how is this
gonna work
do you think yeah holy
smokes that hit like wildfire yesterday
uh obviously there had been some news
regarding harden
because it didn't seem like he wanted to
stay in houston the nets
and the philadelphia 76ers had engaged
in conversations with the rockets
so i think a few things were played here
one the relationship with the rockets
for harden was irreparable so that made
this
time frame change extensively
and i do think the nets were interested
from the very beginning and
also interested in making sure
philadelphia
did not acquire james harden so there
were a few games being played here
uh the nets feel like now they've got
the star quality divide for a
championship they put their
chips right to the middle of the table
they are all
in how it all plays out from a
basketball standpoint
i'm not sure and obviously the kyrie
irving situation
is one that you can't just dismiss is he
coming back
when is he coming back what's his
mindset right now
is he committed to this team all of
these are
reasonable questions and there are no
real answers right now until
he comes out and addresses them
personally well i guess the questions
uh for kyrie could be you know amended
as well
ayan as to where why did he go away at
all
and and why wouldn't he be all in
on all of this where is he uh you know i
mean
we could keep going but but can you give
me an omnibus answer to
what you refer to as the kyrie irving
situation
yeah i just don't know much you know
first of all
it's it's a private manner so i i don't
know what he's going through if this is
something
very personal that that he's dealing
with and then secondly
just based on the circumstances right
now in professional sports
there's very little access you don't see
players i
literally have not seen a net in person
since the start of the season i've not
seen a coach everything has been done
virtually i went through an entire nfl
season i didn't see one player i didn't
see one
head coach i didn't see one assistant
coach so
the normal back and forth that you enjoy
when you do this job for a long time and
the interaction
right that helps you do your job better
it's just not there
and we're all adjusting to it it's part
of the deal nobody's complaining about
it it's just
the reality so trying to get answers is
not
very easy right now and i'm not even
sure
anyone has the answers it is a bit of a
mystery
and my hope is we get some facts here
over the next
24 48 hours the league is now involved
because of the video that surfaced of
kyrie at a birthday party for his dad
and and for a sister
and now it becomes a serious matter
where the league is going to have a say
in when and if kyrie irving returns not
just
the nets and kyrie irving making that
decision iron eagle here on the rich
eisen show a couple more minutes left
here on the nets i guess one thing
you have to you have to deal i guess
in in what we already do know in that
regard
um and and two things one i think i can
see
just sitting from my couch here in los
angeles and the other i'd love to get
some insight from you
one is durant looks durant i mean right
like we don't have many questions here
right that he's he's the guy that he's
he's all the bill of goods that the nets
wanted him to be when they got him
with his achilles and everything right
yeah and from a play-by-play man
standpoint
you you know the guy is coming you wait
a year
for him to put the uniform on the
anticipation builds and builds and
builds and you think to yourself well
there's no way he can live up to it
right there's just no way
he's coming off injury it's going to
take a little time
it's eight straight games of 25 or more
points he's already tied
a franchise record held by the great
bernard king who's not
ever thought of as of the net right
because he did most of his damage as a
nick durant
is going to breathe breaking many
records a multitude of records for this
nets team and he's done
everything that they've asked him to do
and he's done even more
and now i guess the question would be
about nash if he's ready for
all of this where where kyrie is the
uh the big unknown we're assuming hardin
will just
be hardened once he gets into game shape
and he's in a spot where he's clearly
happy to be yep um and and then put it
all together with who's still left i
mean karis levert was
uh dynamic he was terrific um
you know so so i guess walk me through
nash's readiness for
for a a very uh four-dimensional
gig coaching for the next year yeah
i i would think rich uh the only other
option it had
right now would be dr joyce brothers
that's
that's what we're thinking that it's
gonna require
some deep deep thought to make sure
everything is in line
to juggle the personalities involved
everything that i've heard up until this
point sean marx just addressed the media
uh was that the guys are all in they've
all said the right things we want to win
that's what you needed to hear not about
individual accolades kevin durant
he wants to win he wants to win a
championship with his team james
harden there is nobody in the nba that
wants to win more
than him his resume is not complete
because he doesn't have the championship
kyrie does durant does this is the
motivation for james harden
and then the kyrie part of it i think
really what it boils down to
is the communication and the fact that
there wasn't any if someone is dealing
with something
i think in this day and age we all
recognize you gotta go deal with it in
the way you have to deal with it and
there's a respect level there
but if you don't communicate to the
people within the organization of what's
going on
that's where the distraction occurs and
that's where the mystery
unfolds and it creates so much more
to this story than there needed to be if
it was dealt with correctly right away
ion eagle here on the rich eisen show
okay so that's the next part of it
uh let's get to the cbs sports part of
it do you have to ask thad for your cbs
sports blazer
or can we just get right into it let's
do a wardrobe change
if we could treat it like the oscars fad
yeah we're good by the way you gotta you
gotta get me thad's number i don't mean
to poach him but uh clearly he's a jack
of all trades
i've only known him for four hours
i don't even understand the dynamic
between the two of them okay very good
uh
you know uh best of luck with that so
okay
uh the bills how for real are they based
on
you you you called their latest when you
called their last
loss as well with the hail mary you've
been exposed to this team
quite a bit what do you think reminded
of that a few times as we were preparing
in western new york nice got a few of
those messages
hey man get a little uh of that
that uh that bad juju that you got in
you and like i
play no role in this you understand that
yes
they also scored a touchdown instead of
what we all assumed was going to be a
game tying field goal
just a couple minutes before the uh
amazing throw by allen i mean come on
now
where were you come on i needed you last
week not sad
i i think buffalo
validated a lot of things and and i've
seen this
with teams where you have a breakthrough
season
and you don't want to talk about the
pressure that comes with it
when you hit the playoffs because that's
really when you're going to be
judged and the bills they did downplay
that i thought they were really
loose throughout the week and in our
conversations with them they handled
everything the right way
sean mcdermott struck the right cord
everybody that we
talked to had the right narrative in
place but
then when things got a little touchy
against the colts and indianapolis
played well
there were some tough decisions made and
certainly questionable decisions
i i get a lot of text during the game
rich and and i look down at my phone
and when it starts to buzz
and not just buzz once every three
minutes buzz
once every 10 seconds when right decides
to go
for the two-point conversion and
when a couple other decisions are made
and there are a lot of guys that lock in
on the analytics and they tell me all
the time that was the right call
that's the right move and i think to
myself okay
but they didn't win the the teams that
make these decisions i
fully understand them i embrace the idea
that there is science behind this
but you have to eventually win in order
to make me a true believer
in all of this and i've had a number of
situations over the last few years
where these things pop up where your
instincts your football instincts tell
you one thing
and then counter-intuitive to what you
believe
is actually happening on the field so uh
with indianapolis they were aggressive
i think uh buffalo had all they could
handle but
josh allen has truly become
one of those qb's that you've got to
keep an eye on now for
uh the next seven or eight years he's
figured stuff out doesn't
clear i think they're going to be
supremely challenged this week
by baltimore ironically i did that
ravens titans game a year ago
traditional weekend
i think baltimore's better prepared
today
than they were a year ago to go on an
extent running i know that's insane to
say when you win 13 games
and you're the clear favorite to go to
the super bowl in 2019
and now here we are a year later for
2020 and into 2021 with the playoffs
i think they're better i just like their
team better this year well it's saturday
night
uh weather for orchard park new york
iron
um i don't know if you're i by the way i
do provide
traffic as well uh on the sixes here um
that it looks like it's supposed to snow
heavily
and the moment when zach moss got carted
off
in the game that you called i thought to
myself well this team moving forward
because i assumed that they were going
to win it the score looked favorably for
the bills at the time even though it did
get very tight at the end
um you know i thought to myself this
does not bode well
in the playoffs if they require a
running game
to either limit the possession for the
opposing quarterback like seymour holmes
or need to win because the the passing
game gets shut down either defensively
or by something
like the weather that genuinely concerns
me that definitely i would think gives
the ravens an advantage
on saturday night yeah a legitimate
point uh tj eldon i believe is back in
the mix but
even with that said buffalo has not run
the ball all that well this year josh
allen has been terrific and i think a
lot of it is a byproduct of the fact
that he just became so comfortable
as a passer and their downfield threats
were real and stefan diggs has changed
the offense
but even when they've had to run would
you have looked at it
and you thought all right they're going
to have to be a running team now
i don't know if that's their bread and
butter as much anymore
is is still there single is in
in that part of the game devin
singletary numbers were down from his
rookie year to a second year the moss
injury certainly hurts because he was a
grinder and a short yardage runner and
dependable
so a good point uh baltimore has to feel
pretty good going in and the fact that
they've gotten
the the whole of our jackson winning a
playoff game
off to the side so that's no longer even
a story
allows them to maybe free up their mind
and just do their thing
and as i mentioned i'm not leaning
towards telling you who's going to win
the game
i just think that the baltimore ravens
are a really good team and the way they
got to this point is going to help them
more than the way they got to this point
a year ago
diane eagle here on the rich eisen show
before before i send you off into your
thursday sir
uh i'm going to give you the floor on
perhaps um
any father's favorite subject which is
their child
or their children your son here we know
in los
angeles is the voice of the clippers we
know we know how noah eagle can call a
game and is excellent at his job
i got to tell you man that nickelodeon
broadcast because i got a 12
i've got a nine and a seven-year-old at
home i wanted to just see
how they would react to it and then once
they left the room because
you know uh they don't listen to their
father um
i i found myself staying with the
broadcast ayan
you know it was it would not have worked
had your son
not been so good at doing the down you
know doing the
nuts and bolts but also bringing what
clearly is
you know uh from your tree here
uh a sensibility and and his own you
know
fingerprint i i couldn't be more
thrilled for you and for him and it was
awesome
it was just great man really was richard
it's the
it's the ultimate compliment everything
that you just said uh
definitely hits me in all the right
places
i had a net game as this game was going
on so it was nets oklahoma city i'm
calling
shea gil just alexander gliding to the
rim
and my phone is blowing up
so my sense was either this is going
really well
or it's going really poorly one or the
other
and you have to be some kind of
masochist if
it's going really poorly that you're
going to check in with the kid's dad and
tell him hey this is a
mess so i then synthesize the
information that it's probably going
pretty well and i got to read some of
the texts
as we had a break and yeah i was blown
away i came home
i ended up watching it off the dvr
and it was amazing as a as a dad my wife
elisa my daughter aaron just our whole
family
and the reaction that we got how well
received it was i was just really happy
for noah because i know he put a lot
into it he was so excited about it was
so
different and new and the novelty of it
and nate burleson and gabby and
lex from nickelodeon everybody wanted to
do
it the right way the producer ken mack
director suzanne
produced robin's coordinating producer
everybody everybody was committed to
really doing something special well
ken mack and i go back to the u.s open
days you know
um on cbs he's a delightful person he's
a great dad so that makes
i had no idea that he was part of that
bro it was real and
obviously i would have talked it up too
just just for out of friendship sake
uh but i mean every word you know and
and i thought
the the the and i mentioned it here on
the show as well
that the broadcast this broadcast to me
the fact that your son your son was the
one who did it too yours the fact that
your son
was able to properly and easily
explain the catch rule to a child
audience means that the nfl was the
ultimate
latest lock solid piece of evidence that
the nfl has fixed the catch rule
able to make it understandable to
children
it worked it was great you're so right
though but really that's what it boiled
down to and
when i talked to noah that morning i
don't want to inundate him
with 20 things to keep in mind broadcast
i just tried to boil it down to three
things
and i said first and foremost you have
to have command of the broadcast you
have to set the tone of what this is
going to be
nobody knows what you've been talking
about for the last few weeks in your
zoom meetings
and your rehearsals nobody knows so when
you come on the air
the tone has to be said that this isn't
going to be a normal nfl telecast
i said two you got gotta be a point
guard you gotta be able to spread the
ball around you gotta get everybody a
touch that has to be at the foremost
of your focus and then three you must
have fun
if you're not having fun the audience is
not going to have fun and that has to
permeate
throughout the broadcast and i tried at
least you know from a
a dad standpoint advice and then from a
fellow broadcaster standpoint
just to key in on a few things to
to keep your mind right and boy did they
ever did they not check everybody i was
i was blown away
and and just thrilled and and beyond
beyond proud and entertained
also that that's the best part of it
when when it really does
resonate in that manner me too me too i
felt the same way brockman what iron is
doing right now is known as kvelling
that's what he's doing he's
failing right now oh that's what it is
you can look it up
is that brockman of thesaurus thank you
has a yiddish thesaurus he's he's
amazing it's like inspector gadget
that's amazing yes it's that it's that
rosenstein
i and noah and myself all syracuse
orangeman richard okay very good very
good that went to uh
you he went to new house as well go
figure i didn't know that uh
uh not that battle at arts and science
ayan thanks for the call man um i i
truly appreciate it
let's uh let's keep talking i always
enjoy our chats and send my best to
everybody in your household noah
your your wife your child fad you know
your daughter all of them
tell all the eagles i said hello rich
ditto truly
always great talking and i'm glad we've
we've been able to take our relationship
to the next level
we are we are now texting friends we are
that official we are texting friends
thanks anne appreciate it you take care
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here